Patt there may be tapes oh lordy it
seems that there might be tapes I
haven't talked about this story on the
Regular Show because there's been a lot
of conjecture and a lot of speculation
but it is very quickly becoming a real
story and I do want to talk about it now
and it relates to Omarosa Manigault a
fir she recently wrote a book one of
these salacious tell-all type books
where she claims that there are
recordings of Donald Trump using the
n-word
this wouldn't be hugely surprising like
I I don't I don't know that many people
in our audience who would be shocked to
hear tapes of Trump using the n-word but
Donald Trump has been denying that he
uses the n-word never mind they're being
recordings and initially there was this
very aggressive smear campaign against
Omarosa and it worked pretty well
because there was a contradiction in her
tell-all memoir
she said tapes exist of Trump using the
n-word but I haven't heard them more
recently she changed her mind and she
said oh I have heard the tapes and this
appeared to be a contradiction but she's
explained it by saying no when I you
know I wrote the book some time ago at
that point I hadn't heard the tapes now
I have heard the tapes and that's a
plausible enough explanation but this
hasn't stopped the Trump administration
and Trump himself from going into full
denial and smear mode calling Omarosa
all sorts of things
here's Trump on Twitter denying that he
has ever used the word the the n-word
that is just not in his vocabulary he
tweeted yesterday Mark Burnett called
he's the producer of The Apprentice to
say that there are no tapes of The
Apprentice where I used such a terrible
and disgusting word as attributed by
wacky and deranged Omarosa I don't have
that word in my vocabulary and I never
have she made it up look at her many
recent quotes okay and he goes on from
there but that's the relevant part so
now the narrative begins to fall apart
step one was yesterday when a recording
was leaked of Omarosa being fired by
White House chief of staff John Kelly
and that confirms merely that recordings
exist that Omarosa has right all we
learned from that is
Omarosa has tapes and it's not
completely out of the realm of
possibility that she has more than one
tape people who record conversations
with others probably don't do it just
once so yes we at least know that it's
it's plausible that Omarosa has or has
access to tapes the big story happened
this morning where a recording was
released and what the recording
supposedly contains which I'm about to
play for you our trump staffers during
the campaign talking about how to manage
or spin
trump's use of the N word CBS has
obtained this audio what we are told
this is is a conversation involving
Omarosa and remember Katrina Pierson and
other Trump staffers figuring out how do
we spin what Trump said which is
presumed to be the n-word take a listen
then described a conversation she had
with ven candidate Trump about making
the slur so this is just part a it's not
proof that this was about the n-word but
it is about something Trump said and the
three people involved here are I think
we determined Katrina Pierson is black
right it's true three of trumps black
staffers which of course again is not
proof of anything but the lies are
racking up because yesterday Katrina
Pierson claimed on Fox News that this
call never even took place that she
never participated in a call like this
and now 12 hours later we have audio of
the exact type of conversation that
Katrina Pierson that claimed never
happened so this is building pad and
slowly but surely in this drip drip drip
method we're getting closer to
confirmation of exactly what Omarosa is
claiming here yeah I mean everything
Elmer osis says you have to take with a
grain of salt
especially now because she's trying to
sell her books yeah but she said on Meet
the Press that the tape could be saved
for an October Surprise and I don't know
if that's this October or two more
twenty but yeah that would be highly
damaging it could hurt his poll numbers
for a whole week and I think your your
point about what we'll talk about the
impact does this mean Omarosa is a great
person who we should all love and trust
no and she never should have been
working at the White House but more and
more elements of this particular story
are being proven true in Trump's now
furious at Omarosa which is so funny
because when you hire someone that you
know to be crazed erratic and a
backstabber to work for you how are you
then shocked and angry when she ends up
being erratic and backstabbing you again
yeah he fired her three times on the
apprentice and then once from the White
House
but Trump was supposed to hire the best
people that's not happening and I
actually am interested in how do you
spin like let's assume they're
discussing how to spin use of the n-word
how do you spin it you say he was
talking about the country of Niger it
was a conversation about African
diplomacy and he just had like a verbal
typo or a Freudian slip of some kind he
said [ __ ] he was quoting rap lyrics
right there was no ER on the end this
was merely him talking about the rap
songs it like ha what kind of context
can you even invent to make this
reasonable from Trump's usage there
would be no excuse for him saying it at
all but I mean the context would matter
like is he using it like how Bill Maher
used I don't ever write back verses and
you know an insulting way like there are
there are differences their context can
make it as we talked about yesterday on
the story about race baiting where mere
use of the n-word is not necessarily
racist discriminatory prejudicial
whatever Trump just doesn't have a
history of discussing race relations in
ways or I would imagine some benign
usage of the n-word last thing you can
tell how likely it is this is true by
how horrible the things Trump is saying
about Omarosa are and he's now calling
her a lowlife dog he treated this
tweeted this morning quote when you give
a crazed crying lowlife a break and give
her a job at the White House I guess it
just didn't work out good work by
general kelly for quickly firing that
the more insulting Trump is the more
likely historically we've seen proven he
is to know that the allegations are true
send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show will we ever get the n-word
tapes do you think that they exist let
me know today's show is made possible in
part by news voice dot-com slash hackman
we have talked on this program for a
year after year after year how American
media is controlled by just a small
handful really of huge corporations and
the problem with having media
conglomerates among others is that you
get filter bubbles you get echo chambers
and this is something I talked about on
the program a lot there's a new media
company that's come up with an
interesting response to this problem
it's called news voice and what it is is
a website and app for both iOS and
Android which gives you a personalized
news feed by aggregating a mix of
mainstream media sources along with
international sources and independent
media sources importantly so any story
you look at you will get multiple
sources you can upvote stories you think
are important so that more people will
see them you can add a story to the site
you can add a source that's missing for
a particular story and the idea is for
it to be completely open and
democratized as a source of news and you
can get every side of every story check
out the app which you can download for
free if you go to news voice dot-com /
Pakman if you're watching this on
youtube simply click the link below the
video